[Música]
de
co2
[Música]
[Aplausos]
aquí comienza el debate de france 24 mi
nombre es ángela gómez y los acompaño en
este programa para discutir una noticia
histórica falleció a sus 96 años en la
reina isabel segunda del reino unido
tras el anuncio oficial le llega al
trono su hijo carlos en adelante
conocido como el rey carlos tercero que
le espera a la enorme monarquía más
famosa del mundo con las desapariciones
de su representante más longeva pues eso
es lo que vamos a analizar precisamente
con nuestras invitadas en el debate
conversaremos con natalia sobre villa
historiadora de la universidad de kent y
bárbara díaz historiadora docente de la
universidad de los andes en chile ambas
gracias por estar con nosotros y a
nuestros televidentes les quiero
recordar que también hacen parte de esta
conversación dejen sus preguntas y sus
comentarios en nuestras redes sociales
estamos en twitter en instagram y en
facebook en donde nos encuentran como
arroba france24 guión bajo ese y ángel
ago efe 24 me cuenta personaje la
etiqueta es el numeral el debate df 24 y
en youtube pueden seguir nuestra señal
en streaming también saludamos a las
personas que nos en nuestro podcast y no
olviden que todos los contenidos de
nuestro programa están precisamente
disponibles en app el podcast spotify
deezer y tuning
isabel segunda estuvo a la cabeza del
estado británico por 70 años vio la
transición de su reino que comenzó como
un imperio y se transformó en el
commonwealth a lo largo del siglo 20 fue
una de las personalidades más queridas
del mundo hagamos un repaso a los
instantes más importantes de su vida y
ya volvemos con las invitadas de guaje
para la celebración de sus 90 años
isabel segunda visión como de costumbre
un traje y un sombrero del mismo color
una imagen que se hizo icónica en su
destino no estaba al convertirse en
soberana pero en 1936 cuando su tío
eduardo octavo renunció al trono por
amor fue su padre jorge sexto quien se
convirtió en rey
la muerte súbita de su padre en 1952 la
puso en el trono tenía solo 25 años de
edad y su coronación fue vista en
televisión por más de 20 millones de
personas en todo el mundo
tras su entronización vinieron tiempos
turbulentos la decadencia del imperio
británico poco a poco las antiguas
colonias británicas fueron reclamando su
independencia nace entonces la
mancomunidad de naciones en el reino
unido- se vive el swinging london de los
sesentas y la existencia de la monarquía
británica en pleno siglo 20 fue puesta
en entredicho
después de los cuentos de hadas los tres
hijos de la reina isabel se divorcian
uno después del otro en medio de varios
escándalos
el clan real tambalea en
1997 la tragedia sacudió a la corona la
muerte de la princesa diana- sumergió el
reino en un profundo duelo mientras la
reina se escudó tras su silencio una
reacción que afectó fuertemente a los
británicos isabel segunda tardó una
semana en ordenar que las banderas
fueran puestas a media asta
quiero rendirle personalmente un
homenaje a diana ella fue un ser humano
de excepcional talento tanto en los
buenos como en los malos tiempos nunca
perdió su capacidad de sonreír y de
inspirar a otros con su calidez y bondad
jaimes
con el tiempo isabel volvió a ser
popular miles llenaron las calles para
celebrar sus jubileo en 2002 y 2012 las
bodas de los príncipes guillermo con
kate middleton y de enrique con megan
marco así como el nacimiento de los
bisnietos trajeron colorido a una
monarquía envejecida pero también la
garantía de perpetuar la tradición a
través de las futuras generaciones junto
con la empatía del público cuando perdió
a su esposo el príncipe felipe en 2021
en febrero de 2022 su salud causó
preocupación cuando dio positivo por
kobe 19 pero lo superó e incluso dio un
discurso para dar ánimos y esperanza a
la población contra la enfermedad en
junio de 2022 llegó una fecha clave el
jubileo de platino la monarca más
longeva de la historia del país
conmemora sus 70 años de reinado en unas
festividades que duraron cuatro días con
la familia real reunida y miles de
personas siguiendo las celebraciones
aunque isabel se ausentó de varios
eventos por motivos de salud
isabel fue para muchos una fuerza que
dio estabilidad al reino unido- tanto en
los malos como en los buenos tiempos
y vamos a empezar en nuestra
conversación alrededor de lo que fue el
reinado de isabel segunda y para eso
quisiera dar la palabra primero a
natalia sobrevilla la historiadora de la
universidad de dickens natalia un
agradecimiento para usted por estar con
nosotros y la primera pregunta en qué
estado dejo y sabe el segundo la
monarquía y qué es lo que hereda carlos
tercero
bueno la reina en los últimos 25 años
después de la muerte de la princesa
diana ha logrado finalmente volver a ser
la reina de los corazones de los
británicos el jubileo de platino fue un
momento realmente de celebración un
momento de muchísima alegría y deja al
país muy entristecido y desolado porque
son muy pocas las personas que tienen
una experiencia personal de un mundo sin
isabel segunda el 85 por ciento de los
británicos sólo la han conocido a ella
como soberana no ha existido una
transición monárquica en el reino unido
por muchísimo tiempo entonces queda
muchas interrogantes hay bastantes dudas
sobre qué es lo que va a poder pasar a
pesar de que el protocolo es muy claro y
no existe realmente la posibilidad de
que éste piense una aplicación del rey
carlos certero no vi es que ha estado
esperando toda su vida para asumir la
tarea que hoy le fue encomendada con la
muerte de su madre ha sido formado así y
ahora además se llega del lado de su
reina consorte camila parker
y aquí quisiera darle paso a bárbara
díaz también historiadora y docente de
la universidad de los andes en chile
porque carlos tercero en árbol una
imagen un tanto diferente a la imagen de
la reina isabel segunda una persona que
si bien por la naturaleza de su cargo no
puede tomar fines políticos en mi
posiciones políticas si se ha
caracterizado más por expresarse aunque
sea con mensajes indirectos usted cree
que esto podría plantear una diferencia
del reinado que venía y lo que comenzará
a partir de ahora
evidentemente creo que no lo tiene fácil
suceder esto
porque los tantos obviamente para mucho
las maneras
y que carlos ha tenido algunas
tienes políticas
a vista algunas palabras digamos que
mortal
porque está bueno ya están y para eso
tengo los fuertes pero está digamos todo
estar con la política
barbara no le escucho muy bien voy a
tener que pedirle que hagamos una pausa
y mientras se solucionan esos problemas
de sonido voy a regresar con natalia
sobre hebilla natalia después de esta
primera respuesta que usted nos entrega
y sobre la imagen que fue isabel segunda
en 70 años de reinado pues quisiera
preguntarle sobre otras posturas porque
de sus momentos históricos como reina ya
hemos hablado mucho de sus o momentos
destacados y como fue una mujer en una
posición de poder en un mundo de hombres
y de cómo fue una mujer que pasó épocas
enteras que vio ir y venir de 15
primeros ministros del reino unido- y
decenas de jefes de gobierno y de estado
no hemos hablado mucho de lo que
reclaman algunas colectivas en este
momento porque horas después de su
muerte pues hay homenajes hay admiración
pero también empiezan a surgir algunos
reclamos contra una historia de una
antigua era imperial que ella
representaba para colectivas de derechos
también hay que reconocer esa historia
que existe detrás de la monarquía y que
para muchos representa
y una deuda con la historia usted cree
que esa deuda debería ser reconocida
hace que no es tan el reino unido a
visión objetivos que lo reclaman y es
interesante para mí yo llevo más de 25
años viviendo en el reino unido
y es un país con un monarquismo muy
profundo la pregunta es hasta qué punto
ese monarquismo era liga estaba ligado
directamente a la figura de la reina
isabel segunda podrá mantenerse y había
una gran su transición es quien estuvo
presente en toda la segunda mitad del
siglo 20 es más algunos analistas ya
piensan que sólo se ha terminado el
sitio con la muerte de la reina isabel
que tenemos una transición muy profunda
en la década del 50 al 60 la
modernización el fin de la era imperial
y la complicada el complicado legado del
comahue y los deseos de algunos de los
países del commonwealth de dejar de ser
parte de convertirse en repúblicas como
se ha visto en australia sin mucho éxito
pero
cada vez más llamados desde las
y antiguas colonias del caribe jamaica
principalmente que piden reparaciones
que piden que la corona británica y no
solamente la corona británica sino todo
el estado
realmente empiece a entender este
complicado legado histórico
la de otra deuda de isabel segunda si se
quiere ver de esa manera sería como una
mujer que estuvo en una posición en la
que no muchas mujeres pudieron estar en
su época y hoy en día todavía sigue
siendo una posición de privilegio sin
embargo isabel segundo no enarbola
tampoco una postura por ejemplo de
feminismo o de lucha contra la
discriminación el racismo el abuso
sexual todos ellos escándalos que
inevitablemente rodearon a su familia y
rodearon en su periodo como monarca cree
usted que ahí faltó un mensaje o que
esto es algo que por ejemplo podría
aplicar la nueva monarquía que viene y
que pues irónicamente
viene en cabeza de un rey de más de 70
años
bueno comencemos con el caso que la
monarquía es inherentemente conservadora
la idea de la monarquía la la concepción
misma de que el poder debe ser heredado
por familias es una concepción que va en
contra de todas las ideas liberales y de
la igualdad es básicamente el centro de
la nostromo anarquista entonces eso es
por un lado es una institución
inherentemente conservadora en su
naturaleza misma está el conservadurismo
y luego que es una es un rol que no
tiene realmente injerencia política y
que no puede que no tiene derecho a
hablar que no tiene derecho a presentar
una opinión la reina tiene una serie de
tenía una serie de limitaciones de parte
a lo que ella podía realmente de
representar entonces querer pensar que
ella iba a ser una mujer de avanzada que
iba a cambiar el mundo me parece a mí
bastante difícil de concebir el príncipe
carlos ahora a rey carlos tercero
ha tenido una ha tomado siempre una
distancia muy grande con su madre y ha
tenido injerencia política que muchos
han considerado problemática justamente
tratando de enarbolar medidas de a favor
del medio ambiente a favor de los
refugiados es decir él tiene ya un corte
más moderno si se quiere pero también se
trata de un representante conservador de
un país que es muy conservador
y regreso con bárbara díaz hoy confiando
en que ya hayamos podido solucionar un
poco los problemas de audio barbara cuál
es su percepción sobre ese legado que
deja isabel segunda y que deja este
periodo de monarquía que termina hoy con
su fallecimiento
bueno me parece que
y estoy bien estoy de acuerdo con
natalia en
la monarca y así es
conservadora
y tiene que ver mucho con la tradición
británica y los
editores de tradiciones esto
antes
londres y lo veremos ahora tanto
pero me parece que es para por ejemplo
para la eres un ejemplo bien interesante
de una persona es que ha podido
tener en cuenta
enfrentar un mundo muy un mundo de
guerra ya que un mundo que estaba
tratando de levantar de la segunda
guerra
un imperio que se le estaba
deshaciendo
bueno y todos los avatares que
siguieron en el siglo 20 y los estos
años del siglo 21
entonces creo que ella no necesitaba
levantar banderas
de otro estilo o sea ella sola
representa me parece un símbolo muy
interesante para la mujer que quiere
dedicarse a el servicio público
es casi un fenómeno como la reina isabel
segunda cumplió un papel muy importante
al lograr mantener la popularidad de la
monarquía en el reino unido- y por eso
hoy todavía decimos que esta es la
monarquía más famosa del mundo usted qué
opina a natalia sobre estas actuaciones
que a lo largo de 70 años que para nada
son pocos lograron mantener una
estabilidad no sólo en la monarquía sino
una estabilidad que se tradujo para la
nación
bueno muchas personas en el reino unido
que no son veces son artistas
consideran que la reina isabel segunda
ha sido una figura nos ha inspirado que
nos ha llevado a considerar que el amor
y así debe tener todavía una sociedad
moderna otros son más pragmáticos y
dicen bueno es un gran atractivo
turístico es una medida de estabilidad
es un poco o algo que retiene las
personas porque también pensemos que
muchas de las sagas de la vida privada
de estas personas tienen que ver con
mantener al público interesado esa
fantasía que hay sobre la idea de qué
significa ser reina príncipe princesa
del mundo un poco de cuento de hadas y
también un poco también como en la
ficción pop rock o una serie de
televisión que ha sido muy exitosa que
trata de retratar la vida de la familia
real
también contribuye a esta a esta fama a
este halo de misterio que tiene la
familia real y está y que estoy segura
va a conservar porque es no está lo que
va a terminar con la revisaba el segundo
hay muchísimo y lo interés
sorprende siempre como las personas
tienen una opinión pero sé que ni
siquiera son británicas o no viven en el
reino unido tienen una opinión sobre
carlos su consorte camila sobre qué les
parece el príncipe y tienen una relación
como si nos conocieran realmente y al
final eso para mí resulta bastante
llamativo sí sí es en efecto es muy
llamativo y quisiera natale también que
repasaremos un momento histórico
que fue bastante determinante dentro del
mandato de isabel segunda y fue el
fallecimiento de lady di- de diana de
gales que fue probablemente una de las
mayores crisis dentro de la monarquía
que generó impopularidad por su lenta
reacciones después de su fallecimiento
dentro de la manera de accionar de la
monarquía usted a qué le debe esa demora
en el actuar de la reina y bueno es
después de esa corrección audaz que hizo
al aparecer en su funeral al hablar de
ella ya en un contexto más de la familia
real y que luego pues simplemente pasó a
la historia pero isabelle permaneció y
permaneció además siendo una de las
monarcas más queridas del mundo al menos
en el reino unido- así la perciben
bueno en los años 90 en la popularidad
de la reina venían de caída el año 92
ella lo denomina como su annus
horribilis
en el castillo de windsor los divorcios
de sus hijos no se escapan los públicos
y hay mucho descontento con la monarquía
en ese momento y la popularidad de la
princesa aldiana es inmensa pero es muy
interesante yo ya vivía en el reino
unido cuando cuando fue la muerte de la
princesa diana y la reacción popular
pública pues tan impresionante las
personas estaban realmente chocas pero
una semana antes toda la prensa hablaba
de lo terrible que era diana lo terrible
que era su participación e
inmediatamente con su muerte eso cambió
la percepción sobre la reina por no
querer salir en público o por utilizar
códigos muy antiguos de recogimiento de
privacidad
hubo reclamos muy grandes y fue el
entonces primer ministro laborista tony
blair quien la llevó la dirigió y
ejecutó todo un plan para que ella no
perdiera esa popularidad y que poco a
poco fue retomando ganando de nuevo ya
para el julio del 2002 y sobre todo para
el julio del 2012 la aceptación sobre la
reina una mujer mayor
dedicada
que uno tampoco se pone a pensar en lo
difícil que podría ser para una señora
de 96 años tener que seguir cumpliendo
el protocolo es decir ella ya estaba muy
avanzada edad cuando tenía que respirar
la nueva primera ministra liz tras hace
tan sólo unos días entonces es natalia
pues porque no abdicó
porque nunca iba a aplicar por la
historia familiar de la abdicación de su
tío era para ella una decisión clarísima
que ella había nacido para reinar y
moriría en el trono bueno ella hizo esta
promesa en el primer día cuando tuvo que
asumir cuando estaba en este viaje por
áfrica y se enteró del fallecimiento de
su padre repentinamente una mujer de 25
o 26 años que no estaba buscando el
trono que no lo esperaba al menos o que
tan prontamente y que además después en
declaraciones decía que ella no estaba
preparada que no recibió ningún
entrenamiento y que le tocó asumir la
monarquía como venía
porque esa importancia ya pensando en la
ciudadanía esa grandísima importancia de
la parte ceremonial de la monarquía de
la tradición que aún hoy es tan
respetada es que fallece la reina isabel
es de segunda y lo que vemos es que
miles de personas se aproximan a
buckingham palace esperando cualquier
señal entregando sus respetos hoy
llevando flores es llevando canciones
llevando consignas como se explica este
este gran cariño que expresa la
ciudadanía en el reino unido- en general
por la monarquía y por la figura ya
desaparecido de isabelle 2ª primero le
pregunto a natalia y después se bárbara
bueno porque es una institución básica
que tiene que ver con la identidad de
ser británico estamos hablando de
alguien que ha reinado por 70 años y es
la persona que todos consideran casi
como una figura materna ella ha estado
ejerciendo en esa posición ceremonial y
no olvidemos que el valor más importante
de un monarca es su valor simbólico ella
no quiere ninguna injerencia política
ella no toma decisiones ella no hace
ningún cambio ella simplemente
representa a la atracción y eso es algo
que isabel según me entendía muy bien y
que pasó toda su vida dedicada abocada a
esta labor
usted que opina bárbara
y mira yo opino que estoy básicamente de
acuerdo con natalia agregaría que
en un momento en que parece que los
símbolos están en crisis como que ya se
destruyen los símbolos
en muchos lugares
la reina isabel es un símbolo y creo que
eso bueno le ha hecho bien al reino
unido a la población que necesita
necesita ese símbolo de unidad y pienso
que
esto va a seguir no tengo dudas de que
la monarquía va a continuar
no sé cómo va a ser
cómo será pero pero sí que me parece que
que los tiempos no están en gran bretaña
como para para un cambio de régimen
bueno quisiera ahora preguntarle por la
figura de camila parker en adelante la
reina consorte del reino unido- una
figura que ha sido históricamente
polémica por las historias de la
intimidad del entonces príncipe carlos
con la princesa diana- cómo terminó este
matrimonio como esto fue la comidilla
durante años desde los medios de
comunicación británicos y también a
nivel internacional hoy esa mujer que en
algún momento pudo ser percibida como
una mujer o odiada por el público pues
es la mujer que se sienta en el trono
como reina consorte y bajo una figura
muy distinta a como era percibida hace
años es esto un signo de progresismo que
representa la figura de camila parker de
todas maneras es un punto importante en
la historia reciente de la monarquía
por supuesto pero recordemos que la
historia de los poder casi siempre ha
estado plagada de iu y de mitad segundas
mujeres médicas por casarse muchas veces
es decir esto por más de que uno pueda
pensar que es novedoso y nada novedoso
la persona que está casada con el rey es
la reina consorte y me sorprende también
que casi me parece llamativo una vez más
que muchas personas díaz pero me parece
bien o me parece mal el camino a parker
bowles porque da igual
realmente lo que le puede aparecer a uno
la señora parker bowles porque ella será
la reina consorte porque es la tradición
es la tradición la que manda no tiene
que ver realmente con el progresismo
necesariamente recordemos que la
creación de la corona de perdón de la
iglesia anglicana nace del deseo de
micropago de divorciarse en su primera
mujer entonces
yo
no veo la figura de progressive parada y
entonces natalia en qué sentido siente
usted que se ha modernizado la monarquía
al ritmo que se ha modernizado también
el país no olvidemos que el día de hoy
al darse el anuncio oficial habló la
primera ministra de reino unido listos y
al final de su discurso lo que decía era
que la reina isabel había sido esa roca
que ayudó a construir la modernidad del
reino unido que ayudó a forjar el
destino del reino unido
y ello se convirtió en el símbolo de
esta transición del imperio a una
reunión de países que es el como web y
se mantuvo justamente como dice como una
roca
presentando la tradición y la posición
monárquica
y yo no estoy tan segura que estamos
hablando realmente de una modernización
obviamente los tiempos cambian y las
ciertas cosas poco a poco van cambiando
pero realmente lo que vimos también con
el caso del príncipe harry y su mujer ve
a ver tal que si quería traer unos
nuevos aires a la portería se
encontraron que ese espacio no existía
bueno tanto así que no se ha visto a
megan marco visitando balmoral como su
esposo ella se mantuvo en londres
mientras que l se desplazó para estar
junto a su familia y junto a la reina
ahora este este tipo de rupturas que se
ven y que son ampliamente cubiertas por
los medios y bueno una vez más el
amarillismo hace su aparición para usted
son importantes porque al final aunque
aunque se diga que no importa lo que uno
opine de uno de miembros de la realeza
sí o no en el reino unido pues de eso
viven en todas de todas maneras y se
mantienen vigentes porque están todos
los días en las noticias todos todo el
tiempo los vemos en revistas todo el
tiempo nos vemos en internet de un nuevo
nacimiento un nuevo cambio de ropa es
decir la imagen de la monarquía siempre
está presente en la vida de los
ciudadanos
sino porque para la vida diaria de los
británicos es en realidad lo que parte
con la portaría es un poco como una
telenovela nacional y hay muchas
personas a las quienes a quienes
realmente no les interesa yo encuentro
siempre que a nivel internacional el
interés por las pandillas real es
incluso mayor que el que veo en el reino
unido hay mucho respeto se considera que
son las instituciones que son parte
de la idea misma de ser británico pero
la mayoría de personas no están
interesadas en el sombrero nuevo que se
puso la princesa o la reina o la señora
consorte del rey entonces me parece que
además no afecta realmente la vida
cotidiana de nadie va a haber por
supuesto comida así que le dijo si es
que no le dijo las revistas para vender
de eso vive pero la vida diaria de las
personas que cambian
barbara y ahora quisiera ir con usted
para hablar de otro episodio este más
reciente y es el escándalo que rodeó al
príncipe andrew alrededor de unas
acusaciones de abuso por parte de
virginia giuffré quien finalmente fue
resuelto por medio de un acuerdo que
hicieron estas dos personas y pues que
está desarrollado en el entramado de la
red de trata de niñas del magnate
jeffrey epstein como calificaría usted
de ese episodio que marcó
definitivamente la historia reciente de
la monarquía
bueno la verdad me parece un episodio un
episodio lamentable no no podría
profundizar en él
en esto porque no
realmente no es mí
digo no ha sido de mi gran interés de
meterme mucho en este tema
me parece que como decía también natalia
y estas estas cuestiones que afectan a
la casa real
no no mueven a la
él
el hecho de que la monarquía es un es un
símbolo muy grande
así que pienso que bueno si ha habido
muchos escándalos sigue habiendo algunos
serán reales otros serán ficticios
pero creo que este simbolismo se
mantiene y por eso estamos aquí para
hablar de lo simbólica que ha sido la
monarquía en el reino unido- y que aún
no mantiene su vigencia pese a las
desapariciones de isabel 2ª y vamos a
ver a propósito de este tema que venimos
cubriendo desde muy temprano con
france24 un poco el resumen de lo que ha
sido esta jornada que empezó simplemente
con un anuncio de preocupación por la
salud de la monarca y que terminó en un
cambio de mando que estamos presenciando
en directo
[Música]
es un momento histórico y el fin de una
era la monarca más longeva de reino
unido la reina isabel segunda ha muerto
a los 96 años después de reinar durante
70 años pocos días después de que la
reina la nombrará como primera ministra
liz tras expresó sus condolencias
para the news todos estamos desolados
por la noticia que acabamos de escuchar
desde balmoral la muerte de su majestad
la reina es una gran conmoción para la
nación y para el mundo la reina isabel
segunda fue la roca sobre la que se
construyó reino unido- de rock
el hijo mayor de isabel segunda carlos
encabezará un luto del país como nuevo
rey en un comunicado el rey carlos
tercero dijo que todo el mundo extrañará
a su madre
el fallecimiento de mi querida madre su
majestad la reina es un momento de
máxima tristeza para mí y para todos los
miembros de mi familia sé que su pérdida
se sentirá profundamente en todo el país
los reinos y la commonwealth y por
innumerables personas en todo el mundo
las banderas de todo reino unido- ondean
a media asta y el país ha entrado en un
periodo de luto nacional que durará diez
días la familia de la reina se trasladó
a escocia para estar a su lado a primera
hora del jueves después de las
advertencias de los doctores que desde
temprano se dijeron preocupados por su
estado de salud desde finales del año
pasado sufría constantes problemas de
movilidad que lo obligaron a cancelar
casi todos sus compromisos públicos
la reina isabel segunda llegó al trono
en
1952 cuando apenas tenía 25 años
y acercándonos al final de esta
conversación de barberà quisiera
preguntarle cuál es su conclusión cómo
será recordada a la reina de isabelle de
segunda en los años por venir
yo creo que será recordada como
una persona que es
estar en cada momento a la altura de la
circunstancia obviamente en algunos
momentos como todo el mundo pero si
pensamos que ella vivió desde la
el drama de lo que fue la europa
destruida por la guerra
después
todo el tema de la de la descolonización
y cómo después poder no formar
bueno el
commonwealth y mantener una relación más
o menos amistosa con todos los que
habían sido miembros de ese imperio
británico
como pudo también
tener como primeros ministros a personas
tan diferentes como atrás al principio
como margaret thatcher como tony blair
bueno
y pudo
y seguir
siendo
la persona o símbolo de
su país me parece que es también una
buena como
la tercera de estas de una tríada de
mujeres reinas en
inglaterra
isabel primera victoria y sabe segunda
que de la que los ingleses deberían
estar
orgullosos porque cada una
realmente tuvo
y muchísima importancia para la
construcción del estado para la
expansión y el imperio y para guiar
isabel a gran bretaña y al reino unido
en esta etapa del siglo 20
notable a la misma pregunta para usted'
para cerrar
la reina isabel es un icono del 120 la
recordar siempre como la persona que nos
llevó al reino unido a el cambio de un
imperio a un estado más moderno
y efectivamente coincido muchísimo con
la visión que se presenta de las tres
reinas más destacadas de el reino unido
que son la reina isabel primera la reina
victoria y la reina isabel segunda se
habla mucho de la era de la isabel es la
primera y hay una nueva era de isabel
que se está e isabel segunda yo creo que
para el pueblo británico va a ser
siempre un referente y será muy
interesante ver cómo logra su hijo para
rossi su nieto guillermo seguir con este
legado pues bien muchísimas gracias a
las dos zonas de natalia sobre villa
historiadora de la universidad de cannes
y bárbara díaz historiadora y docente de
la universidad de los andes de chile un
agradecimiento a ambas y lo han dicho
muy bien es el fin de una era los 96
años falleció la reina isabel de segundo
quien ocupó el trono británico durante
los últimos 70 años según el anuncio de
la familia real la monarca falleció de
manera pacífica en el castillo de
balmoral y ahora lo que sigue son los
homenajes para una de las mujeres que
fue contada entre las más poderosas y
queridas del mundo sigan con nosotros en
france 24 nos vemos después del debate
[Música]